Trying to keep in shape while traveling long term and not use,
not having gym access as an excuse for letting my standards slip.
Best pieces of kit training styles from maintaining conditioning and adding mass
while living out of the bat.
Pattern.
Get rings.
Yeah.
Gymnastics Ward.
Gymnastic rings.
Why wood plastic or metal will make you get sweaty and slept in.
You have to bring a ton of chalk.
You need a little bit of chocolate would rings.
It's a little will resorb there's the best thing to grab onto get would
gymnastic rings.
You can carry them anywhere and then just do a bunch of calisthenics.
I mean,
come on man.
Just on knows what adding mass,
how do you add Mascara?
Oh,
you gotta get creative.
Yeah,
you gotta get creative,
but it's,
do you know,
instead of doing squats,
you know air squats do jump squats or doing some dynamic dro one plyometrics.
Yeah.
Do one legged pistols.
All that stuff.
Yeah.
That's the key.
I got to do that right now.
Like I can't,
you can drill.
The hole inlay is called the owner.
So they drilled a hole in the attached to the tendon nut in the hole.
They go,
they pushed the tendon through the hole,
they put an anchor at the end of the school.
Boom.
Anyway,
a lot of swelling in the forearm.
You can't grab nothing,
you can't grab anything and have weight.
So calisthenics you got to kind of make your position,
your wrists in a position,
in a comfortable position and you can do the dead anyway.
Point there is I'm in that boat or lifting weights is not an option at this very
moment for me.
So you got to kind of get creative.
So like a push up,
you can make the pushups harder.
If you put your feet up in the high,
he put your feet,
you know the harder it becomes or you do like a one arm pushups situation and
then you can do like a d client like um,
you know you go on a counter first.
Right?
Okay.
How many of these one arm pushups?
You can do more than 20.
Okay.
Maybe go for like a chair or something like this.
Something,
something a shorter boom,
you can do more than 20 of those.
Okay.
Now I can go to the ground,
see what I'm saying?
And then you can go raise your feet up as time goes on.
Boom.
There you go.
Good for.
And actually body weight through space is the best way to build size.
Um,
in your muscles there as far as like exercises go,
that's good information.
It is better than dead lifting and squatting.
Well,
okay,
so that dead lifting,
squatting,
that's going to be um,
is going to depend on the weight.
But think about this.
Dead lifting and squatting is moving your body through space.
So doing an air squat,
you're moving your body through space as opposed to med squatting with weight.
Right?
And still come back squat.
Right,
right,
right.
But what on squat?
Yeah,
getting help you with squats yet.
But again,
like I said,
moving your body through space is the,
are the best exercises for mass and what is,
what is not moving your body through selects squat compared to a leg press.
Yay.
Why haven't even,
those aren't even in my,
those aren't even in my mind.
I know brow,
but this guy asking the question,
okay,
it might be cool.
I'm trying to help him out.
I don't want to help you out.
You got the whole exercise thing figured out.
I get it.
You know you're an expert in your boring workouts.
Talk about that later.
None.
The less body weight or body moving your body through space is the best
exercise.
The problem is or tends to be that your body has a fixed amount of weight more
or less so you can't adjust the weight and usually you can move your body
through space a bunch of times.
If you do air squats,
you can do a bunch of air squats so it doesn't provide the quote unquote tension
that you need to build mass.
That's why you go one at a time.
Create more tension on your muscles while still moving your body through space,
which could wind up to be a better exercise for you.
That's what I'm saying.
That's good advice,
man.
Whatever Brad don't act like is crazy that I'm saying this stuff.
That's the question.
Really the question you were talking about with this whole moving your body
through space thing.
Yeah,
that's external information.
No idea what that I kind of get it now when you were saying it as if it was some
unknown.
It is unknown.
Even your body through space.
Okay.
So you know what a hammer strength machine is.
So it's all,
you know,
it's like a,
I don't know,
like a lever kind of thing.
Technically it's like,
you know,
you put some plates on it,
you push it,
there's no pulley or nothing,
but you know,
you're not moving your body through space,
you know,
moving your body through space.
So I'm kind of creating the spectrum here,
so could just consider that.
Then it's kind of far down this other movement or things that are further down
the spectrum,
but that's fixed movement.
There's no balance required.
There's no whatever.
It's just like you're just pushing weight.
It's isolation.
Isolated.
Yeah.
Plane.
The plane is isolated.
All this to the plane of movement.
Cool.
Right.
So that we'll have less neural muscular activity when you push it.
Even if you're pushing heavy weights than something like graduate to like a Bar
Bell,
bench press,
right,
for example.
But even that,
even that you do have to balance.
So that's a big step up.
But even that you don't have to balance in certain planes,
certain planes of movement,
you don't have to balance like the,
what do you call this one lateral whatever,
the lateral movement and a bar bell bench press,
which is the bar.
You don't have to balance,
it's fixed,
but front and back or forward and forward and back,
whatever.
You do have to balance.
So you know,
still good.
Now go to dumbbells.
Now you have 360 degree plane of movement that you have to balance more neuro
muscular activity.
So dumbbells are better than barbells in that way.
No muscular activity and you can adjust the weight.
So you can do things where you can only do three reps,
you can do things,
you can do 20 reps if you want.
So boom,
great exercise.
I can't really do it in a hotel room,
but just saying generally speaking,
good exercise.
But now you go the tip top.
The best exercise for neural muscular activity would be pushups because same
you're moving your body through space.
You're not balancing weight.
Your balance on the rings even better.
Now you're going like creative,
which is good.
That's like beyond the spectrum which is good.
Totally good.
But so yeah,
keep these things in mind.
I think when you,
when you do a thing,
so if he can add or window workouts.
So when you,
if you can add weight,
that's the challenge.
If you can add weight to these moving your body through space exercises,
that's when you get again that exercise.
Now I'm just going to take this one step further.
Do it cause you don't necessarily have to add weight as you stated earlier.
Yes.
You can adjust how you're moving your body through space and then you can get
the,
you can get additional and I'll tell you what really makes us obviously is if
you do any gymnastics training,
if you do a pull up,
that's hard.
If you do a talk,
pull up where your knees are pulled up,
that's even harder.
If you do an l sit,
pull up where your knees are up,
put your feet are pointed straight forward,
that's even harder.
Each one of those things is a little bit harder.
Same thing with a dip,
like just a regular dip.
If you've got your feet hang,
it's easier if you bring it up to a talk is a little harder.
If you bring it up to an l it's even harder.
So you can keep doing these things and there's squats you can do,
I mean just doing pistols alone,
that's a lot harder.
Some people can't even do pistols.
Yeah.
And so you might have to do an assisted pistol.
We'll start off.
Yeah.
So yeah,
you can make it happen.
His little Kinda Hardman is,
especially if you've never done them before this,
it's hard because the balance balance back and side to side balance 360 degree
plane of balancing.
That's what this whole thing's about.
Moving your body through space.
Is that what it is?
Where did you read that?
Uh,
old school Bulgarian Phil Philosophy Workout Program called is the old school
never deviated from much the core.
Really good too,
by the way.
Um,
it's called what it's called.
I remember the serious growth is what it's called weird,
right?
Like that's such a lame name,
but man,
I was in high school and I was like,
all right,
you know,
you read all these things right.
And you know,
in the back of the,
uh,
you know,
Muscle magazine or whatever and the little article,
I remember all the Bulgari and kind of like,
uh,
that was a big thing.
No kidding.
Well,
yeah,
because the Bulgarians were doing really good at weight lifting at the time.
No one knew it was weird and these guys were like,
yeah,
five weeks or four weeks,
my bench went up to this and you know,
when you're in high school band tech yet,
but I'll get that or whatever.
So you get the permanents his book,
it's just got serious growth and it explains everything really in detail too.
I was like,
Dang,
this is pretty good,
real plain English to not elders rule science or whatever.
And maybe there's hope.
And they were doing Quito too,
by the way.
That's where I learned about this 90.
That's crazy.
It's been around for a long time for Nickelback.
Ken's book came out in the sixties or seventies.
Yeah.
That's way different though.
It's not,
it's not a way different.
Yeah,
it's different.
Way Different.
Yeah.
This was,
this guy has just been around for a long time.
Yeah.
Mark,
Dr Mario or Morro de Pasquale [inaudible].
That's who was the Quito Gut.
And again,
back in [inaudible] 94 he's still around.
Yeah,
no kidding.
So yeah,
so we did this thing,
we get this book and it's like laying it out and you know,
I'm down.
I'm 15,
16 years old.
I'm down to lift five days a week.
Let's do this and brow.
We did it.
And you eat good.
Not like crazy.
I didn't do the Quito.
Never did.
Um,
but you know,
they have it as an option and so we did it or whatever.
And we,
it was weird since I gained like 20 pounds and I just,
we just kept doing it.
So,
you know,
you play football,
you can't really gain,
there's also this whole thing that you're 15 and your body's just filled with
testosterone.
You going to gain 16 pounds anyways,
I'm telling you,
I'll tell you this right now.
I was talking to Jody Mitic about this briefly too.
If even at 40 you go on this thing,
it depends on how you train.
No,
no.
Go on this,
this type of work,
and I'm not even like selling this work on it or nothing like that.
I'm just saying this'll people will think and think.
You know what though?
Okay.
People will think you're on steroids.
If you do this workout for like six weeks,
that's it.
Six weeks they'll think you're on steroids.
Straight up like my whole life when I'd like go on a on a like a six week thing.
They're all,
he's on steroids.
Obviously.
He's uncertain.
No steroids.
You don't even have to take supplements.
That's the weird thing.
But here,
let me say this though,
now that I'm thinking of it as or about it when I'm a grown adult,
most programs,
if you actually do the whole program exactly how it works,
it works really good.
That's the thing.
People just don't do the workout.
Oh,
what do you need to do?
Lift heavy weights a lot.
Eat good in rest.
Good.
Yeah,
you'll get,
and let's,
and let's face it,
it's not,
is like if someone says,
oh yeah,
it's easy.
Here's the thing,
it's not easy.
This is why it's not easy.
It's not just the workout.
That's why you have to do the workout.
Then you have to eat enough of the right things too,
by the way.
And then you have to rest enough.
That's basically you have to change your whole life.
So if you're like,
hey,
it's easy,
just change your whole life.
It's not easy.
So,
and not that,
I'm not saying that that's a good excuse or anything,
but I'm just saying it's not quote unquote easy,
but yet there it is.
Jack,
do a diet,
exercise,
eat good workout,
good and rest good.
You'd be good hotel or Jim,
actually,
here's what you can do.
Here's what I do want to go to the muster or wherever.
Even if I'm there for like a week,
like the last muster,
all like go on Google maps and find like all the gyms and be like,
all right,
I'm going to,
that's kind of the commitment.
Obviously.
You know,
that's an interest.
That's your commitment.
Like you want to stay in shape,
add mass,
as you say,
conditioning,
adding mass,
whatever it look for the gym near Your House.
Commit to pay that Jim feeds.
She's like,
what,
10 bucks?
Or something like that,
and boom.
That's the commitment right.